- Al right, everybody.
It is time for Drew's News.
Sit back, relax, and kick up your feet
on your good news ottoman.
With me at the desk is the one,
the only, Rossy Ross Matthews.
- Yes!
(audience applauding)
Hi, everybody.
Hi!
Hi.
- Hi.
Sorry, I gotta clean my glasses.
- I love this bright
are blue on you today.
- You do?
- Yeah, I tried to like-
- You mean like your bright electric blue?
- Yeah, but I just like
hop on the Drew train.
(audience applauding)
- We're like that couple.
- We're totally that couple who matches.
- All right, well boy,
am I happy about this.
Breaking movie news.
We're gonna a Nancy Myers movie.
- Thank God.
(audience applauding)
- [Drew] You guys, Nancy Myers
is responsible for, oh gosh,
I mean Baby Boom.
- Baby Boom's at the top
of my list, of course.
I have a list here.
Father of the Bride, It's
Complicated, The Holiday,
Something's Gotta Give.
(Drew screams)
And that's just a few of them.
(audience applauding)
I know.
- Funny enough, I was in a movie
that her and her husband directed called
The Reconcilable Differences.
- Oh my God, of course.
- I worked with Nancy back in the day.
So she went into retirement.
She said, I'm done.
I'm not making movies.
And we all cried.
- [Ross] Yeah.
- But Deadline just literally
reported that Netflix,
of course, brilliant,
inked a deal with the legendary filmmaker
to write, direct, and
produce a brand new comedy.
Now we have no idea what it's about
(audience applauding)
or what format it'll be in.
It's just that it's an
original ensemble comedy.
It'll be Nancy's first movie since 2015,
when she made The Intern
with Robert De Niro
and Anne Hathaway.
I mean, I am chomping at the bit.
This was hot news to me.
- And I'm already
obsessed with this movie,
and it hasn't even been written yet.
So thank you, Nancy Myers.
All right, speaking of movies,
we were so thrilled when
Troy Kotsur won the Oscar
for best supporting actor for CODA,
(audience applauding)
becoming the first deaf man to
ever win in Oscar for acting.
- And then CODA won best picture!
- [Ross] I know
(audience applauding)
- It's like, oh my God!
- Love that movie.
Well now Variety reports,
Troy recently celebrated
his love of movies
by recreating some of
the most iconic lines
in movie history in
American Sign Language.
- I literally think that
he is just everything.
I love him so much,
and I am so happy to see
him doing stuff like this.
It's just such a delight.
He's so wonderful.
- He is so wonderful,
and he was so great in this movie.
If you haven't seen CODA yet, watch it.
He'll make you cry,
but he will also make you laugh.
(audience applauding)
Did you see what he posted on Twitter?
- No.
- This is so cute.
Ever wonder how people
get their Oscar home
after they win it?
Like can you put it in
the overhead compartment?
- I've never, no, I've never
had to worry about that.
- Well, not yet,
but so this is how he got his Oscar home.
He tweeted this picture.
Look, he drove it home,
and he buckled it in.
How cute.
He had like a six-hour
road trip after the Oscars,
and I just thought that was so cute.
- Okay, this is exactly
what I'm talking about.
Like, can he get any more wonderful?
He's the most charming, wonderful person.
Now I've got that visual with him.
- I know.
- It doesn't stop, Troy.
- What will he do next?
I can't wait to see.
(upbeat music)